veamos la hidratación de alquinos
empezaremos con el alquino terminal de
aquí puedes ver que hay un hidrógeno en
un lado de nuestro alquino Y en el otro
lado de nuestro alquino digamos que es
un grupo alquilo enlazado a este carbono
en la derecha añadiremos agua ácido
sulfúrico y sulfato de mercurio do a
nuestro alquino lo vamos a hidratar
ahora hemos visto la reacción de
hidratación antes hicimos una reacción
de hidratación con un alqueno y añadimos
un h+ y un Oh men a través de nuestro
doble enlace y haremos lo mismo aquí
añadiremos un h+ y un Oh men esta vez a
través de nuestro triple enlace y el Oh
men siempre se añade al carbono más
sustituido vimos eso en nuestro video
anterior la
Regio
química muestra la regla de markovnikov
solo escribiré la
regla
de
Mark
aquí hemos pasado mucho tiempo hablando
de la regla de markovnikov en videos
anteriores lo que significa que esta ohd
aquí en la derecha
se añadirá al carbono más sustituido el
cual Resulta ser el carbono en la
derecha ya que eso se enlazará a un
grupo alquilo aquí en la derecha el h+
agrégalo por aquí a este carbono en la
izquierda Ahora hay dos hidrógenos en la
izquierda Así que añadimos h+ y Oh men
añadimos agua esencialmente a través de
nuestro triple enlace y obtenemos esta
molécula como nuestro intermedio esta
molécula tiene un nombre específico se
llama
eol la
en viene del hecho de que hay un doble
enlace presente en esta molécula y el
ool viene del hecho de que hay un
alcohol este Oh de aquí Así que este
enol es el intermedio de esta reacción
sin embargo el enol no es la forma más
estable de esta molécula por lo que de
hecho se va a reordenar y obtendremos
una
cetona como nuestro producto y te
mostraré el mecanismo para este
ordenamiento en pocos minutos obtenemos
una metil cetona de un alquino terminal
esta reacción es mejor usada cuando
estás buscando hacer una metil cetona Y
estás empezando con un un enlace triple
aquí Así que veamos una
reacción empecemos con un alquino
terminal pondré un grupo metilo en este
lado del carbono así y reaccionar este
alquino terminal con agua y
ácido
sulfúrico y con sulfato de mercurio do
así si pensamos en lo que pasará estamos
añadiendo h+ y Oh men a través de
nuestro triple enlace añadiremos el Oh
men al carbono más sustituido ese sería
el carbono en la
derecha tenemos al carbono doblemente
enlazado a otro carbono añadiremos el Oh
al carbono en la derecha añadiremos el
h+ al carbono en la izquierda hay agua
añadida a través de tu triple enlace y
luego aún tenemos otro hidrógeno en este
carbono aquí en la izquierda y luego el
grupo metilo Aún está aquí en la derecha
Ese es nuestro enol intermedio déjame
solo volver a dibujar esta
molécula esta molécula es
equivalente a esta molécula de aquí la
dibujaré de esta manera desde ahora esta
es mi forma enol y mi enol se
reordenar Esta no es la forma más
estable de esta molécula veamos el
mecanismo de cómo se reordena nuestro
enol continuemos dibujando nuevamente
nuestro
enol aquí abajo hagamos un poco de
espacio así Aquí está mi enol pongo mi
doble enlace pongo Mi par libre de
electrones así este enol está presente
en una mezcla ácida H2O y h2 so4 y Me
darán iones hidronio en solución h3o má
habrá
h3o + flotando alrededor en
solución tenemos nuestro hidronio de
esta
manera esto por supuesto es capaz de
donar un protón y los electrones pi van
de hecho a irse y tomarán un protón
así y luego estos electrones se moverán
a tu
oxígeno Así que esta es una reacción
ácido base como primer paso por lo tanto
dibujamos nuestras flechas de equilibrio
aquí así y veamos qué pasa bien
tendremos este es nuestro
esqueleto el
Oh aún no hace nada y añadiremos un
protón al carbono del lado izquierdo de
tu doble enlace
así continuemos mostrando Cuáles
electrones se movieron los electrones en
tu enlace pi cualquiera de estos enlaces
de aquí es tu enlace pi esos electrones
se moverán y formarán un enlace con este
protón
así terminamos quitando un enlace de
este carbono de aquí tuvimos un doble
enlace que quitó un enlace de ese
carbono eso dejará a ese carbono cargado
positivamente y hay una carga formal de
+1 en ese carbono y podemos dibujar una
estructura resonante para este
intermedio
continuemos dibujando nuestro paréntesis
de resonancia y nuestras flechas de
resonancia
aquí y qué podemos hacer con nuestros
pares libres de electrones para
compartir esa carga positiva podemos
tomar uno de estos pares libres de
electrones y podemos moverlos a acá para
formar un enlace doble entre nuestro
carbono y nuestro oxígeno
continuemos haciendo
eso un doble enlace se forma entre
nuestro carbono y nuestro oxígeno así
Ahora solo hay un par libre de
electrones en este oxígeno de arriba y
si pensamos en lo que le pasó a nuestra
carga formal de hecho se mueve aquí a
este oxígeno por lo que este oxígeno
Ahora tiene una carga formal de
+1 esa es nuestra estructura resonante
para esta molécula en la izquierda ahora
al oxígeno no le gusta tener una carga
formal de más un tampoco hay alguna
manera para que este oxígeno se deshaga
de su carga formal de + un Y por
supuesto que la hay hay agua flotando
alrededor el agua actuará como una base
un par libre de electrones en el agua
tomará este protón solo ese protón
dejando estos dos electrones atrás en mi
oxígeno así por lo que tenemos otra
reacción ácido base continuemos
mostrando esta reacción de atrás en
equilibrio Así que dibujo mis flechas de
equilibrio así y ahora tengo mi
oxígeno tenía un par libre de electrones
alrededor Ahora tiene dos pares libres
de electrones
alrededor
ahora
hemos terminado formamos nuestra versión
cetona Esta es acetona nuestra cetona
más simple tenemos la forma seto del
producto Esta es la forma
seto del producto en la forma de una
acetona y luego tenemos nuestro
enol por aquí se dice que la forma
acetona y la forma enol son tautómeros
el uno del otro y están en equilibrio el
uno con el otro y pueden ir y
venir Y en este caso estamos usando
ácido para catalizar esta transición
esto es
llamado
tación
catalizada
alizada
por
ido
así y vamos y venimos entre la forma
zeto y la forma enol también la
escucharás frecuentemente como
tautomerización
seto en
[Música]
noc
así así que la forma ceto y enol están
en equilibrio una con otra ahora el
equilibrio de hecho favorecerá la forma
zeto Esta es de hecho la forma más
estable Esta es
más estable por lo que ese carbono
doblemente enlazado a un oxígeno para la
forma aceto es más estable que el
carbono doblemente enlazado a otro
carbono en la forma enol y esencialmente
estás cambiando un protón y un enlace pi
en este equilibrio Y esta es la forma
catalizada por ácido de este mecanismo
en el siguiente video veremos una
reacción muy similar donde hacemos una
tautomerización catalizada por una
base